good morning believe nation today's
message is be true to yourself over to
you Hilary Clinton you know the advice
that my mother gave me when I was
growing up is advice I think about every
day you know what well you know you have
a choice you can either be the actor in
your own life or you can react everybody
else who's going to try to pull you into
their drama and you gotta just be
you just you just have to be as true to
yourself as you can and you know and
lots of times the best way my mother
gave me advice was not by telling me
what to do but by asking me questions
are you sure like what she just said
like the consequences are you sure this
is the right path I love this message
one of the things that I've discovered
and I continue to discover and learn
about myself as I get into new projects
is when I am emotionally invested in a
project and really want to do it and it
makes me come alive that's when the
project has success and anytime you take
on a project that is just a financial
gain or for some other reason other than
you absolutely love in what you're doing
it doesn't work out you deal with people
who aren't great you end up with a
product that you're not proud of and you
feel like just have that regret that
desire the same man why did I get into
this project and so every time you go
into something new you want to think
about are you being true to yourself I
was connecting with a young entrepreneur
this morning and he mentioned that he
wanted to go to Silicon Valley because
that's where all his competitors are
that is literally the single worst
excuse the worst reason for wanting to
go to Silicon Valley right to wanted to
go anywhere because your competitors are
there go for the weather go for the
customers go for anything else but you
don't go because your competitors are
there right you want to go because it's
a place that will help make you come
alive and help make your dreams come
true so the question today today is are
you being true to yourself and how are
you or how are you not leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot a vinspresso
this race Oh give me go away